[Music]
well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages as they come in time then to
see what is making the headlines with
the guardian's chief political
correspondent jessica elgot and the
daily telegraph's deputy political
editor lucy fisher great to see both of
you as ever front page is first though
let's start with the telegraph quoting
the health secretary sergey javid's
warning that nhs waiting lists won't
begin to get shorter until at least
the times reports that boris johnson has
been issued a warning by mps that his
plans to clear the backlog aren't
ambitious enough
according to the eye a million more
children look set to go hungry as the
cost of living crisis continues
the financial times has word of bp
voicing its opposition to a windfall tax
on the profits of oil and gas companies
the guardian reports on a group of
conservative mps who are accused of
trying to derail the government's own
green agenda
and the metro has the latest on the
court case involving footballers wives
rebecca vardy and colleen rooney
well quick reminder that by scanning the
qr code that you'll see on screen during
the program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's get the very latest
from our guests tonight jessica elgot
and lucy fisher
welcome to both of you um let's go
straight to the financial times in this
mini reshuffle what were the highlights
for you then
well lucy me i think one of the most
interesting moves was jacob rees-mogg
who's been made uh minister for brexit
opportunities at the cabinet office
he said uh previously that it would take
half a century for the country to
realize the benefits of leaving the
european union boris johnson has made
clear to him today that that is to be
sped up drastically so he's been tasked
with coming up with an action plan
of identifying a thousand eu regulations
that still exist within uk law that can
be torn up in a big blitz of red tape
what's interesting about the ft story is
they pick up on some concerns um not
least from the international chamber of
commerce warning that actually whether
it's consumers businesses or civil
society it's not necessarily wanted to
see a big bonfire regulations um the the
head of the international chamber of
commerce makes the argument that in this
country people value high standards and
that needs sharp regulation to keep
those in place but i think the
government is very aware that during the
eu campaign it was promised that brexit
would make life better daily for
citizens as well as for businesses and
so far the changes we've seen have just
been very symbolic in nature things like
restoring the crown symbol to pint
glasses and the prime minister is
anxious to make it clearer to people how
brexit will benefit them day-to-day
and the accusation i suppose is that
many of the difficulties of brexit have
been hidden behind
the problems of the pandemic and it
comes isn't it as not only the the
northern ireland protocol is at issue
many people importers and exporters
talking about the paperwork the new
customs rules the cues we've seen at
ports so there's a there's a lot to look
at here isn't there jessica
yeah i think i think there is and and it
strikes me that that jacob
has been given
two briefs actually he's also the
minister for government efficiency which
is incredibly difficult and i mean at
the beginning when he when when the
title was announced was some sort of
scoffing in westminster it was kind of
an invented job but brexit opportunities
um you know is it a tricky one for all
the recent reasons that you and lucy
mentioned and i mean the cabin office
produced uh to mark the anniversary last
week a really weighty document which was
supposed to you know all the great
things we've done since we left the eu
and a lot of it was
incredibly thin i mean it got very
little coverage in the end um
and at the moment most of the you know
talks of bonfires of red tape well a lot
of businesses have seen in a hugely
increased red tape uh since brexit it's
it's caused a lot of extra bureaucracy
and government efficiency i mean you
know getting getting hold of whitehall's
procurement policies it's not not
something i would have necessarily um
associated with jacob rees mogg's
talents but again something you know uh
that maybe he feels strongly about
working from home whitehall civil
servants etcetera so um so it'll be
interesting to see how he avoids these
bear traps in his new position
uh metro also covering this story as
well um lucy i don't know if we've got
the full page actually but it's great
photograph of the lithuanian prime
minister nearly walking straight past
the door which is just still on broad oh
it's just above that anyway we've cut it
off never mind another time but
meanwhile johnson shuffles the pack to
ease the party's hangover lots of
mention of mark spencer um becoming
leader of the house while he himself is
under investigation but um any notables
about this this um you know this
lots of the word he shuffle and
everything because there's not that many
women involved
well that's right i think it's
interesting today that no one got sacked
it was a lot of sideways shuffles and in
the case of mark spencer labor
criticizing uh him being moved into yet
another cabinet position moving to jacob
rees-mogg's old role as commons leader
given that he is under investigation for
uh allegedly being involved in telling
nazrat ghani a former transport minister
that muslimness had been raised as an
issue when she when it was discussed
that she would be fired from that role
and return to the back benches so the
opposition's seizing on on that and
suggesting the government isn't taking
that inquiry seriously by keeping him in
the cabinet i think generally just shows
that boris johnson you know hasn't had
the authority to be able to kick people
out um from his front bench he's had to
sort of try and accommodate everyone he
can't afford to annoy further mps and
risk any more people joining the revolt
against him and as you say you know
there's been a lot of criticism today
that this is the he shuffle or the men's
shuffle it really has been mainly male
figures in the top ranks and a few women
latterly um added to the roster later in
the day but only after that criticism
had really seasoned hold so i i think
it's only a mini reshuffle i don't think
there will be hugely rebounding effects
from it but certainly it does raise
scrutiny about boris johnson's attitude
towards some of the female talent in his
party
i mean while the other focus of
government today uh was the uh the issue
of waiting lists the the nhs reset plan
um and the depressing news that we've
got at least another two years of of of
rising numbers on those waiting lists
jessica uh before it starts to get
better despite more money being thrown
at the issue
yes and and java's making the point in
lucy's paper that
actually there is very little the
government can do and of course it's
convenient for java to make this point
but you know it sets out you know
reasonably persuasive one that because
the backlog logs are so high because so
people so many people
stayed away from the nhs um during the
pandemic and when they didn't feel it
was an emergency and there will be long
waiting lists there's even with this
increased investment and people are
probably going to be expecting to see
significant results because we're all
getting a tax rise in april and you're
expecting that that night that you know
that that by 2024 um
99 of patients will be waiting less than
a year i mean that's still
you know making a year that target still
makes people
we'll probably still make people uh
flinch quite a bit and with some of the
dire warnings that we've seen and about
the the state of the council waiting
lists
on the front of pages and the run-up to
to this plan
and you know speaking to people in in
government i think that they they really
do feel like this and perhaps even more
than the cost of living crisis you know
maybe even dare i say it more than
parties
is going to be the the issue that could
really mean that the party comes across
at the next election
and uh top of the times as well uh
johnson accused by his own mps of
oh hold on a second i'm reading the
wrong one there's that the uh i'm just
trying to read it it's so tiny for me oh
tori's pushed me empty to act faster on
waiting list to apologize and that was
my my problem um yes so what do you
think of the plan uh as outlined today
lucy you know will it take things over
faster um you know what struck you as
actually fixing some of this issue
which feels insurmountable for many
people waiting depressingly and
not even being seen at the start of
their treatment programs
well i think there are reforms in this
plan that will make a difference um
within you know several years time that
includes things like a new web platform
so people have all their information at
the touch of a fingertip they can see
where they are in the queue new one-stop
shops for cancer tests in shopping malls
and football stadiums also new surgical
hubs for getting operations done quicker
things like knee operations hip
replacements cataracts so i think that
there are um some good ideas in this but
i do think that the timetable will be a
worry to many in the conservative party
in the government as jess says you know
this is looking at getting waiting lists
starting to come down in 2024 well that
seems awfully close to the next election
for the conservative party to start
making any difference and i think
obviously the paper today comes after a
delay we know there's been rows between
the department for health and social
care and the treasury the treasury has
been concerned that you know they want
to see um the most stretching targets
possible and value secured for the 5.9
billion pounds capital investment that
the health service is getting i think
there's just increasing concerns that
health services sucking up ever and
bigger portions of day-to-day spending
as well by the state and some people
worry that it's just a bottomless pit in
to which money is poured and yet you
know things never seem to get better so
i think uh there are some good ideas in
there but the the time it will take for
these to take effect um is potentially
concerning yes and without social care
bit being fixed people stay in hospital
longer than they would do that's always
been part of the problem hasn't it but
uh the other issue as well our front
page of the eye jessica this cost of
living crisis um talking now about
children going hungry and whether in
fact the issue of free school meals
could be changed whether whether that
could be reset itself to offer school
meals to more families
yeah i mean it's a very interesting
question um
and one that has been you know obviously
controversial in the party i mean boris
john one of boris johnson's biggest
adversaries in in in the first year
of um of the pandemic was marcus
rashford the the footballer who
campaigned so passionately on um free
school meals and extending them over the
school holidays i mean in fact that's
something that people have have argued
should be the case and you know even
outside the the extraordinary situation
of a pandemic and and i think now that
we're obviously seeing really
significant pressures on on family bills
um you know amongst people who just
don't have that extra that extra give
you know a tax and potentially a tax
rise and potentially um
you know obviously seeing the effects of
inflation um seeing the effects on
energy bills i mean there are
mitigations to help some of the most
vulnerable families but ultimately it
still looks like that people looks like
people will will go see you know out
out of pocket and
therefore you know is it is it about
looking at how to you know
more steps to help
you know that extra uh category of
vulnerable people that would be pushed
into
um that poverty and because of the extra
pressures
lucy you must study these things is it
always this hard to be prime minister i
mean i know you know right you know we
go way back and you've had the financial
crisis then then brexit and then the
pandemic and now we've got this massive
cost of living issue i mean it's it's no
fun in politics is it when when the
stakes are so high on every subject
well i think you're right but i also
think in a way um during the pandemic it
led to the suspension of politics as
normal we saw the conservatives leading
the polls for such a long time during
the covet crisis i think in part because
the government um sorry the public gave
the government a bit of a break people
recognized um that this pandemic
sweeping the world was a novel virus it
was a pretty unprecedented situation and
even if there were missteps um taken
that you know the government was
probably trying its best so i think
people largely gave boris johnson the
benefit of the doubt i do think things
are going to be much tougher as this
year goes on with the cost of living
squeeze with energy bills going up in
april just at the same moment that
national insurance contributions are set
to rise council tax is set to rise the
personal um threat income the personal
allowance and the income tax thresholds
are going to be frozen inflation is
soaring it's going to be a really really
tricky time i think this eye front page
brings out you know some of the worst of
people that who could be hit a million
more children could go hungry that's
just an astounding number and i think
again when you put that against some of
the other headlines around tonight bp
headed for eight year record high in
profits i think that there will be more
pressure on the government to try and um
redistribu redistribute some funds to
make sure that the hardest stuff in
society don't go without
well fascinating anyway but uh you're
right it's uh you know it's massive uh
massive and seismic issues for all
families isn't it uh this subject as we
roll through the next year um coming up
there are some tory mps trying to
undermine their own government's green
agenda we will talk about that and more
after this break
[Music]
watching the press preview with me once
again jessica elgot and lucy fischer
welcome back to both of you um so let's
go to the guardian shall we um tory mp
is accused of trying to drag the climate
fight into a new culture war this is
after rishi sunak um gave full some
backing to north sea oil and gas as a
means of transitioning our way through
this um jessica what's your thoughts on
this
well i think that you know that this is
a group that has had some publicity um
especially because um
many of them have were key figures in
the in the brexit fight including steve
baker and have drawn on some of the
tactics that they used um in order to
get publicity for for you know opposing
theresa may's uh brexit deal um but i
think that um one of the interesting
things about this story is how um you
know senior climate scientists are
saying that they're very worried about
the
the pressures of this of this group and
how they believe that they're having an
effect in shifting government opinion i
mean they are that they are small in
number but there's a number of quite
effective operators in there as well as
baking people like um steve halphon um
and uh and
and others and i and i think that you
know
there's a lot of touring people will
tell you that they're really on board
with the with the you know the climate
fight and boris johnson seems you know
particularly personally involved in it
and there's even been another group set
up to try and counter this group so the
sort of net zero support group or
something i think it's called um but
yeah i think one of the things that is
you know pretty significant about this
story is is the influence that the
scientists perceive
they're having and and it's like the the
examples are like the ones that you you
gave with rishi cena
um very quickly lucy your thoughts on
that i mean a lot of these people are
very familiar to uh the old the old
brexit research group aren't they by the
look of them
well that's right and i was also struck
last week by the uh suggestion that
nigel farage another leader of the
brexit uh movement um said that you know
for his next move in politics he was
potentially interested in getting
involved on a referendum on net zero i
think the argument a lot of these
skeptics are using is that it's all very
well for britain to make really
ambitious targets about phasing out
fossil fuel cars or replacing gas
boilers with heat pumps but really it's
a drop in the ocean when you look at the
kind of major pollution coming out of
china where they're still using
coal-fired power stations some of the
pollution coming out of the u.s
and other developed nations they argue
it shouldn't fall all or shouldn't fall
so disproportionately on the shoulders
of uk consumers when they're facing a
cost of living crisis
jessica i'm i've only left you 10
seconds for your favorite story which on
the front of the metro very very quickly
you'll have to do it later but tell us
more
i mean it's just a fantastic story with
so many details about this wagon for
christy between the two um footballers
wives who where it went ugly and i just
urge you to all read the details about
how phones were dropped and then you'll
see
it's really spectacular
well jessica and lucy thank you both
very much indeed